I keep seeing Tech reviewers that are
calling the new M3 iMac a disappointment
and I will admit that I had that same
initial reaction after I found out that
Apple didn't really change anything at
all other than the M3 chip but now that
it's been a month with the M3 AAC in her
office doing a bunch of testing
comparing it to other Macs I've realized
that everyone is
[Music]
wrong
what I'm going to do in this video is
discuss the true market for this new M3
iMac as well as compare its performance
to the previous best 27in Intel iMac to
give you guys some perspective because
recently everyone's complaining that the
new iMac just isn't fast enough but
everyone is once again dead wrong first
of all the 24in iMac is meant to be a
very high quality reliable desktop PC
for the regular consumer destined for
somebody's home office for things like
business work General web browsing and
being a homework machine for students
and at a base price of
$1,300 it's very well worth it
considering that you're getting a
complete all-in-one package that's
incredibly easy to set up and move
around without a ton of cables
everywhere with an included highquality
keyboard and mouse a 1080p webcam
and a topnotch 4.5k retina display that
looks better than many external displays
out there and most important of all it's
running Mac OS which is extremely
reliable paired with an apple silicon
chip which is incredibly quick Snappy
and Powerful but the problem with
everything that I just said is that all
of those statements were already true
with the previous 24-in iMac that was
released back in
2021 so so as far as a regular consumer
machine there's essentially no real
world difference since the design and
feature set hasn't changed one bit
however if you look at this from a
techie point of view someone who
actually cares about high performance
Computing this machine is an absolute
Beast thanks to the new M3 chip so why
in the world is everyone complaining
about it being a disappointment well
probably because it's it's a boring
update with no design changes and it
shares the same old regular base level
M3 chip that you get in the new Macbook
Pros but what a lot of people are
missing is the fact that this new iMac
offers the least expensive way to get
that new M3 chip basically $300 less
than the M3 MacBook Pro and on top of
that the performance of the M3 doesn't
really seem that impressive because
everyone is testing and talking about
the new M3 Pro and M3 Max chips which
are much more impressive but then we
started actually testing this M3 iMac
which by the way our model is the one
with the upgraded 16 gigs of RAM for
$1,500 since we have already confirmed
that the base 256 gig SSD has the same
singleand storage chip issue so you kind
of need the extra Ram if you want to
have decent performance now the first
thing I want to do is compare this new
M3 iMac to the previous best iMac you
could buy the 27in 5K model which came
out in 2020 with the craziest Intel I9
10 core CPU 64 gigs of RAM 512 gig SSD
and a 5700 XT GPU with 16 gigs of vram
first of all the new M3 chip has almost
double the single core performance which
is useful for so many common tasks
including web browsing and webbased apps
we actually tested web browsing
specifically and to my shock the M3
scored 3.5 Times Higher and you can
actually feel the difference in
snappiness with pages and plugins
loading faster in terms of multicore
performance the M3 iMac was
55% faster and keep in mind that this
thing has an insanely thin chassis with
only a single fan that's connected to
the Chip's heat sink compared to the
huge cooling system in the old 27-in
Intel iMac and keep in mind that this
performance is going to translate to
basically every other app that relies on
multicore performance like programming
and much more but the craziest part was
when I tested 3D rendering in blender's
BMW project and the M3 IMAX somehow beat
the the Intel iMac with the crazy
dedicated 5700 XT GPU which by the way
scores 77,000 points in geekbench 6's
Graphics test which is 63% faster than
the M3 Chip's GPU because of the
dedicated raay tracing cores and all the
other Apple silicon features the M3 chip
was so much faster so all of this
basically proves that anybody that's
still stubbornly holding on to their
27in iMac is dead wrong about the
performance of the new 24in model yes
the display is a little bit smaller with
4.5k resolution instead of 5K but the
huge list of advantages outweighs the
loss in screen real estate but now let's
forget about the past forget about Intel
let's just talk about Apple silicon
itself because I did compare the
performance of this new M3 iMac to the
M2 Pro chip in the 14-in MacBook Pro
because one of my personal predictions
was that the regular M3 would outperform
the M2 Pro now in terms of rck
performance that unfortunately did not
happen with the Bas M2 Pro chip still
clocking in more multicore performance
on the CPU side albeit not too far off
which is pretty impressive but on the
graphics side the M2 Pro was a huge 58%
faster in terms of graphics performance
however those are just benchmarks so
let's start to look at performance in
the real world tests that people
actually use on a day-to-day basis
because this is where it gets very
impressive because of the 14% higher
single core performance which is used
for lots of common tasks the web
browsing performance got a big boost
being
177% faster which gives us pretty much
the snappiest internet surfing that
we've ever ever seen that in turn also
improved the performance of web design
in figma this right here is a project
from 500 designs one of the best Design
Studios based out of California and in
the export test the new M3 iMac actually
finished 1 second faster which of course
isn't much but it's still impressive
that a base chip is beating the previous
Pro chip now in terms of CPU rendering
performance in the new cinebench 20 24
which is even more optimized the old M2
Pro chip was only 7% faster and that's
after a 10minute stress test but then
cinebench now has a brand new GPU
rendering test so I tried it out and to
my surprise the regular M3 iMac was a
whopping
19.3% faster than the M2 Pro so I went
ahead and tested 3D rendering and
blender and holy smokes guys the M3 iMac
was actually 24 seconds faster in the
party tug Cycles GPU render even though
the M2 pro has a massive 58% higher RAW
graphics performance in geek band 6 this
is of course purely due to the new rage
tracing cores in the M3 family of chips
that are doing the heavy lifting giving
you better performance in the real world
I even tested the classic BM W render
and once again the M3 iMac beat it out
and guess what I tested video editing in
Final Cut Pro and for the most common
format that people shoot video in today
which is 4K h.265 or hvc footage they
both finish the export in exactly the
same time 2 minutes and 20 seconds
because they both rely on the hardware
encoders which are the same I also
tested photo editing performance in
Lightroom classic exporting 50 raw 42
megapixel photos and here the M3 was
slower but not by much just 11 seconds
slower I also tested programming
performance in xcode and here it was 16
seconds slower so definitely not as fast
but it's close enough to be honestly
really impressive with the performance
for the price the only area where the M2
Pro had a significant Advantage was
logic pro music production being able to
run 153 tracks instead of 116 without
overloading because of the extra
performance course but with all of that
said and tested it's pretty clear that
everyone was wrong and the new m3i Mac
is just about the best bang for the buck
modern Mac that you can get right now
with incredibly impressive performance
for the price but keep in mind that
you're going to want to upgrade to 16
gigs of RAM if you care about
performance but for the average Joe that
just needs a reliable office PC the base
model will be just fine giving them a
futureproof machine for the next 10
years no problem so hopefully you enjoy
this review and if you did go ahead and
subscribe above and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next
[Music]
one